get ready to fall in love with malignant
that's got to hurt i don't care where
you're from okay i didn't mean that
literally but let's move on james won
the man behind such beloved horror
classics such as insidious the conjuring
and aquaman comes at us with his latest
spine tingling entry malignant so in
this video we'll be taking a look at its
ending it's shocking twists and details
you missed along the way but before we
begin make sure to like and subscribe or
my parasitic twin will take over and
force me to do videos on only romantic
comedies i mean those can be terrifying
too hey i know that it's the company
that always copyright strikes me well
here's the warner brothers logo stylized
to make it look like an old vhs tape and
that's because vhs tapes play a large
role in uncovering the mystery of the
movie it's basically a device used to
get out a lot of the film's exposition
so we opened on simeon research hospital
in 1993 and you just know when a
hospital looks creepy as [ __ ] nothing
good can really happen here the director
has also decided to tinge some of the
windows in green which is commonly used
to represent sickness on recording we're
introduced to dr florence weaver a
surgeon at the hospital conducting
research on a boy named gabriel
apparently none of the therapies are
working on him and he's a little bit
violent
it also appears that he can manipulate
electronics around him
well that's nice so dr weaver seeing no
alternative course of action decides to
cut out whatever is making gabriel sick
it's time
we cut out the cancer i mean the film is
called malignant which has a double
meaning one a disease or infection and
two evil those of you paying close
attention may have noticed these pink
panda socks on gabriel not really what
you'd expect a boy to be wearing in 1993
so keep that in the back of your mind
that pun will become evident later on
flash forward to present day where we're
introduced to our main character madison
mitchell she's pregnant coming back from
a long hard day's work to be greeted by
her gem of a husband derek how many
times i have to watch my children die
inside of you that was
i'm called for but really the worst
thing he does is wear his shoes on the
bed so he's mad i guess that she's had a
bunch of miscarriages it's really insane
and ends up slamming her into the wall
and the back of madison's head splits
open of course spousal abuse is in
automatic sleep on the couch but in the
middle of the night he's awoken by the
sound of a kitchen blender going off and
something tells me it isn't madison
making a late night smoothie as derek
investigates he sees the fridge door
open the tv turns on by itself and a
strange long-haired figure is in the
living room although my favorite was
when the couch cushion pops up like mine
does after i've binge watched 10 hours
of netflix derek is attacked by the
figure and his head brutally twisted
apart later that night madison wakes up
with some casual blood on her pillow
which for me was a typical night in
college and finds her dead husband she
too is attacked and knocked out the next
day madison wakes up in the hospital
next to her sister sydney she has to be
the bearer of bad news telling madison
that her baby didn't make it this is now
her fourth miscarriage in the last two
years sydney didn't actually know this
fact and only hears it from hunky
detective kokoa which is hawaiian for
warrior and you might be wondering why
sydney in this next scene is wearing a
princess outfit she works as a princess
for kids birthday parties the fact she
does this for a living has no bearing on
the story whatsoever but this is a
screenwriting technique called pope in
the pool basically when you have a lot
of exposition in a scene you want to do
something to distract the audience that
they're being spoon-fed information and
in this case it's dressing up one of the
characters as a princess thank you for
coming to my ted talk derek's body is
autopsied in cocoa along with her
partner regina who for some reason is
allowed to suck a lollipop in front of
his dead body another pope in the pool
example find out that the handprints
found on derek's body are upside down
this is another important clue but with
no signs of forced entry and the
knowledge derek was an abusive husband
madison is looking like a top suspect
two weeks later madison heads back home
to where she shared so many happy
memories with her husband and locks up
the place she tells her sister that she
thought this time the baby would work
out i felt so real this time
i just couldn't do enough to protect her
and later on she confides in her sister
something i found to be worded really
odd a reason of why she wanted a child i
wanted to know what it felt like to
to have a blood connection with someone
a biological connection and sydney's
like i'm your biological sister hello
but here we get our first twist of the
movie madison isn't sydney's sister at
least not biologically she was adopted
when she was eight years old just before
sydney was born across town a series of
grisly murders occurred the doctors who
worked on gabriel as a child are being
hunted down one by one and brutally
killed something madison witnesses
firsthand as she is transported as if in
some sort of astral projection she can
see them but they can't see her kokoa
who's in charge of investigating these
murders finds that dr weaver kept
records of all her patients and guess
who just happens to be one of them a
young madison before she was adopted
although her original name was emily may
so now madison has a connection to these
new string of murders everyone who is
dying once treated her at simeon's
hospital meanwhile a woman who runs
tours of seattle's underground is
kidnapped by gabriel or at least that's
who seems to be committing all these
crimes yes gabriel madison's imaginary
friend wait
are you saying that the killer is
your imaginary friend this woman is only
known as jane doe although there's a
reason for this as later on in the film
we'll learn this is actually madison's
biological mother who is being kept
alive for reasons yet to be explained
and as things get more twisted for
madison she's even taunted by gabriel
who let them tell you i wasn't real
no
i am going to make them pay for what
they did searching for answers madison
questions her adopted mother asking her
if there was anything weird about her as
a kid and boom some vhs evidence here we
see nine-year-old madison communicating
with her imaginary friend gabriel
madison's mother thought this creation
was just her way of coping with the
trauma she went through as a child and
it eventually went away meanwhile kokoa
searches for the last surviving doctor
but it's too late gabriel has gotten to
him but kokoa finds him you know just
chilling on the ceiling and a foot chase
ensues in which we just see how messed
up gabriel's body is his joints seem to
pop in and out of place worse than my
grandmother but this allows him mad
flexibility as he nimbly outmaneuvers
the detective and escapes with madison
wanting to unlock the past she does the
only logical thing and acquires the help
of a hypnotherapist there we see a
flashback of young madison being told by
gabriel to cut a piece of her birthday
cake but instead she awakens hovering
over the bed of her mother holding a
knife madison thinks gabriel wanted to
hurt sydney who at the time was still in
her mother's belly saying it's as if he
knew that
with you here
i wouldn't meet him anymore so now we
have a jealous homicidal imaginary
friend in our hands hey remember
madison's biological mother who got
kidnapped well she's cut through her
confines and escapes only to fall
through the ceiling and straight into
madison's living room yes her biological
mother has been tied up in her own house
this whole time they even find all of
gabriel's weapons in the attic now the
detectives are like hey do you think
madison's doing all these murders so
they lock her up during madison's
interrogation kokoa receives a call from
gabriel
really doesn't have an explanation for
this so until they can sort things out
madison will be held in jail meanwhile
sydney travels to the now abandoned
creepy simeon research hospital to
uncover clues about madison's past
apparently madison's real mother serena
was raped at the age of 15 and forced to
carry the child to term her devout
christian parents saw the child as an
abomination and thus made her give it to
the hospital and it's here we learn the
real mystery of what's been going on
gabriel is an actual part of madison a
parasitic twin that was mostly cut from
madison's back although they couldn't
remove all of him as it would kill
madison they also share parts of the
same brain being able to access each
other's vision like in this shot here
where gabriel can see the apple the
doctor is holding up while madison
recites what the image is gabriel was
cut apart and the pieces they couldn't
remove shoved into the back of madison's
head but when derek pushed her into the
wall and she bashed her head open it
awoken him once again for years gabriel
has been feeding off madison even
consuming her fetuses which is why she
had so many miscarriages and because
gabriel can access those parts of the
brain that control visual stimuli he can
make her see what he wants her to see i
think he's able to trick her mind and
make her think she's living her life as
usual essentially placing her
in a mental prison so this whole time
it's been gabriel using madison's body
like a puppet to commit all these
murders it's here we get one of my
favorite sequences in the entire film
gabriel takes over madison's body kills
all the women in her cell and escapes
captivity in the worst thing that
happened to a police department since
terminator i'll be back it's a massacre
and i just gotta throw this clip in
there it's just too funny
the climax however takes place at a
regular hospital where gabriel and
madison's biological mother recovers
from her fall sydney arrives knowing
this is where gabriel is likely headed
and we get this cool shot where the
security guard's pacemaker explodes in
his chest because gabriel can control
electronics i'm not sure it's ever
really explained how he can do that but
i'll ignore because the deaths are
pretty cool as gabriel is about to kill
sydney serena wakes up telling him she's
sorry and that she should have never
given him up but it's a little too
little too late and as he's about to
kill her kokoa shoots him but is stabbed
by gabriel's weapon gabriel pins sydney
against a hospital bed and in a
last-ditch attempt to reach at madison
she tells her how gabriel has been
feeding off all her babies hence the
miscarriages it was a cause of your
miscarriages he was feeding off of your
fetuses to build himself back up but
that doesn't work and she's shot in the
head and serena is killed or so we think
just like gabriel could control what
madison saw so too can madison control
what gabriel sees him killing sydney and
serena was all a ploy by madison who has
found the strength to lock him away now
i can do all the mind tricks you can he
tells her he can't lock her in forever
and she agrees but next time she'll be
ready it's a fun little comment that
leaves the possibility open for a sequel
and with madison returned to her body as
she hugs her sister and her mom creepily
watches on madison tells her sister the
moral of the story i've yearned for a
blood connection with someone
yet in the end it was right in front of
me all along
and as everything seems hunky-dory the
film ends on a buzzing of a light bulb
reminding us that gabriel is still there
literally in the back of her mind one
could make the case that this movie is
fundamentally about a woman being able
to make her own choices about her body
with everything that's going on in texas
right now it makes for a topical subject
and there are several times throughout
the film where madison's dialogue
expresses this it was always my body
if he was strong enough to do this
then so am i
you don't get to control me ever again
and control is what men and those in
power do to madison throughout the film
taking away a woman's ability to make
her own choices for herself it starts
with serena who's forced to take the
baby of her rapist to term then madison
herself who is forced to be experimented
on when she does grow up she's
controlled by an abusive husband and
after that she is literally under the
control of gabriel her parasitic twin so
you can see that at its core malignant
is a story about control specifically a
woman's ability to make her own
decisions about her body but what did
you think of malignant will this be a
wand classic to sit alongside insidious
in the conjuring or will it fall by the
wayside let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone
remember to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you